est ce la sécurité sociale eh bien on y
verra peut être un peu plus clair
bientôt la ministre de la santé simone
veil a annoncé ce matin la création
d'une commission des comptes de la
sécurité sociale cette commission
permettra d'informer à la fois les élus
et les usagers sur le budget de cette
gigantesque machine qu'est la sécurité
sociale son budget je vous le rappelle
est comparable au budget de l'état
les explications de ces de simone veil
pardo sur cette commission ça répond on
veut que la population elle-même soit
mieux informée je crois que c'est un
domaine qui la concerne de très près ce
sont l'ensemble des cotisations payées
par tous les français qui constituent
les recettes de la sécurité sociale
l'avis de tous les français est affecté
par les dépenses de la sécurité sociale
il est tout à fait normal que les
français souhaitent informer de ce qui
est fait de cette masse considérable
d'argent par exemple ça permettrait de
mieux comprendre en quoi consiste le
déficit de la sécurité sociale
c'est ça c'est ça je crois qu on
comprendra pourquoi la prévision est
difficile à faire
pourquoi il ya des éau pourquoi il ya
parfois en cours d'année ou au fil des
années des ajustements à faire entre les
recettes qui sont prévues qui ne
rentrent pas forcément et surtout en ce
qui concerne les prévisions dépenses qui
sont quelquefois plus forte que ce qui
avait été envisagé